if you have a question or a theory about
conspiracy theories in this country and
in the history of the world now's your
chance to call in the phone numbers 20
27 37 00 02 or 20 27 37 00 01 also 20 to
60 to 80 205 joining us from Fort Worth
Texas is Jim Marrs his latest book is
called ruled by secrecy mr. Mars thanks
for being with us well it's always a
pleasure I'm going to begin where your
book begins and that is the trilateral
commission what is it well the
trilateral commission refers to the
trilateral nation's of Japan North
American Europe it was formed in 1972-73
by David Rockefeller and several other
members of an even over secret society
the council on foreign relations which
has certainly an undisputed lead Amin
ated US foreign policy since at least
World War two now you have to understand
I call both of these societies secret
societies and I they're not secret there
in the phone book to have websites but
call them secret societies because you
and I can't join we we could go with a
fistful of money and say here I'll pay
all the do's and let me become a member
and that won't cut it you still will not
be a member you have to be inducted you
have to be asked and you have to go
through a very stringent screening
process and they have to make sure that
you your views are their views and only
then are you brought in I noticed as a
matter of fact just the other day that
Katherine Harris the Attorney General of
Florida who did so much for stopping the
boat counting and and thus putting
George W Bush into the presidency was
just inducted into the Council on
Foreign Relations so you see that this
is not just some knitting Society this
is these are people who are movers and
shakers and decisions are made in these
secret societies that end up affecting
us all as you point out in your book
when you say CFR council for on foreign
relations among the members listed early
in the book Peter turn off Anthony Lake
Al Gore Warren Christopher colon
all les aspin James wolseley William
Cohan Joan Adelman Spiro Timothy worth
winston lord lloyd bentsen Laura Tyson
and George Stephanopoulos also former
trilateral members include Bruce Babbitt
Stephen Bosworth William Cohen Thomas
Foley Alan Greenspan Donna shillelagh
and strobe Talbott what does this mean
well this means that some of the most
powerful people in this country who are
in charge of formulating and
implementing our public policy all
belong to this cozy little group it
meets and that has certain agendas and
we have to ask ourselves how much
influence did actually have I give you
an example in 1954 following the French
military defeat at dim pimp you in what
was then French Indochina we had John
Foster Dulles who was then secretary of
state to Dwight Eisenhower went to the
Philippines and created something called
sito the Southeast Asian Treaty
Organization and he later said this was
done simply as an excuse to give the US
president the legal stand to for
intervention in Southeast Asia in other
words this was the beginning of the
Vietnam War back before right after
World War two the Council on Foreign
Relations had published some papers
saying that we needed to gain control
over the resources in Southeast Asia so
this was one of their game plans and
John Foster Dulles had been a founding
member of the Council on Foreign
Relations so see I think we have to pay
very close attention to what these
people do because their attitudes and
their agendas and their issues that they
discuss in their private meetings all
too often become public policy after you
talk about the trilateral commission and
the Council on Foreign Relations you
then go on to talk about the
Bilderbergers you describe it as a group
of powerful men and women many of them
European royalty who meet in secret each
year to discuss the issues of the day
many suspicious reaches researchers
claim they conspire to manufacture and
manage world events despite the fact
that many highly regarded American media
members meet with the Bilderbergers
little
or nothing gets reported on the group or
its activities leading writers to claim
censorship and news management that's
right it's one of the most well-guarded
meetings ever wear anymore by the way
I'm sorry where did they mean they need
at various places usually private
resorts they are so secretive they
really don't even have a formal name
they're called the Bilderbergers because
they were first discovered meeting
publicly it at the bilderberg hotel in
holland back in 1954 believe it was
again this past year they met in Europe
and one of the items on their agenda
that did leak out was that they thought
that interest rates in Europe were a
little bit too low and they met at the
first of June and by the end of june
interest rates in Europe were moving
upwards so I think you that you have to
again you have to understand that these
people are movers and shakers now let me
put it this way what if all the owners
of the national football league
franchises were to meet in a hotel under
heavy guard and allow nobody in no news
media know anything meet for a few days
come back out and say we're not going to
tell you what we talked about or what
was discussed wouldn't the news media
raise holy hell I mean wouldn't they
yell collusion price fixing everything
else you know restraint of trade and yet
here our movers and shakers of the
corporations that basically control our
lives and they meet once a year by and
closed doors and with armed guards and
the news media we don't get a peep out
of it they act like it's not happening
in putting together this book ruled by
secrecy was there one thing that you
learned or one thing that struck you in
doing research for this well yeah I
think the thing that really blew me away
was that you find out that within these
secret societies now let me stress Ralph
about that everyone who's a member of
the trial our Commission of the Council
on Foreign Relations is not some
sinister plot or in fact most of them
are really on honest well-intentioned
people but there is an inner leadership
core that really makes decisions and
what I found in was quite startling was
this inner leadership core is all inter
related by blood by marriage by
associations by business connections and
they track all the way back the
trilateral commission was an offshoot of
Council on Foreign Relations the foreign
Council on Foreign Relations was a
outgrowth of Cecil Rhodes as old round
tables this was an offshoot of what was
known as aluminized Freemasonry now we
get back into the Freemasons the the
first third party in this country was
the anti-masonic party so it goes all
the way back through the days of Andrew
Jackson back to the founding of this
Republic and even further back Jim Marrs
joining us from Texas what's your
background by the way I have the green
journalism and was a journalist in the
dallas-fort Worth area for a good number
of years have published my own newspaper
and then began writing books my first
book of course was crossfire the plot to
kill Kennedy which became a basis for
the Oliver Stone movie JFK let's get a
call from Tulsa Oklahoma good morning
good morning call you with us hello go
ahead please yeah I was wanting to speak
with Jim Marrs actually I was trying to
talk with Andre earlier but I had a
horrible time getting in there but I've
always been fascinated with these
conspiracy theories and I just noticed
one the other night about the landing of
the Americans on the moon about how to
have never happens and there's many many
scientific and optical facts to prove
that had never happened I was wondering
what you had to say about that well of
course this gets back to a long-standing
controversy and allegation that the
first moon landing may not have actually
taken place and that it was somehow
staged on a in a movie studio I don't
really know I can't tell you anything
for sure I think that there seems to be
some legitimate questions certainly
about the first moon landing now I don't
believe that anybody I haven't heard
even heav'n the conspiracy theorists
argued that some of the sub
moon landings did not take place so I
think that it's safe to say that we did
go to the moon so we're really not it's
not a question of did we or did we as a
question of degree you know did we
actually make that first one to fulfill
President Kennedy's pledge that America
would have a man on the moon by the end
of nineteen of the 1960s or did we
perhaps fudge a little bit and and but
then go on and make it up in subsequent
landing so it's just a matter of degree
I don't think that's a huge controversy
Los Angeles your necks good morning for
Jim Marrs if mr. Mars how you doing I
would like to discuss the Federal
Reserve and it's an elaborate printing
press where it creates money out of
nothing then we are then we barter with
it and then it's a private corporation
there's there's there's private stock
with the physical owners and then this
public common stock could you please
explain how we've been duped into this
printing press and there's nothing
behind the press well I that's of course
is an important part of my book rule by
secrecy is about the Federal Reserve
which is neither federal nor hasni
reserves it's really in fact it's
fascinating one of the most contentious
issues when our founders of this country
were put together the structure the
constitution bill Bryant son like that
one of the most contentious issues was
whether or not we wanted a central bank
and they knew from their experience in
Europe that central banks tended to loan
money to governments and pretty soon
we're running the government's and they
decided they don't want any part of that
even though there was a couple of ill
fated attempts of a central bank do you
bank of the United States and the bank
of america but neither which really
worked out so we really didn't have a
central bank until nineteen thirteen and
when nobody was particularly looking in
fact it was rammed through like a day or
two before Christmas when most of
Congress was doing something else and we
got the Federal Reserve System and what
I found very fascinating is that
throughout most of my life they were
very careful not to refer to this as a
central bank
can yet all within the past 10 years or
so it's just on the news and everywhere
else they just plant you know yeah the
central bank today said and so we got it
and it was slipped in on us again
through secrecy your other book alien
agenda do you think there is life on
other planets yes i think so i think
that statistic wise if nothing else i
think would be very foolish not to
believe that there's probably life on
other planets how advanced do you think
that life is as far as whatever
technology they may or may not have or
information or transportation or
anything along those lines well they're
advanced enough to know better than to
come and and mess with us because at
least on an overt basis you know they're
not here if there are intelligent
species out there off our planet i I
don't think that it's necessarily a
fearful thing primarily because if they
do have advanced enough technology to
travel through space and to come in to
visit the earth they would certainly
have the technology to destroy our
cities or to wage war on us or whatever
Allah the movie Independence Day and the
fact that this hasn't happened is a
strong indication to me that that's not
their agenda San Mateo California is
next for Jim Marrs who is joining us
from Fort Worth Texas go ahead please hi
mr. Mars I really I applaud you for
writing this book but it sounds like to
me that you also might have read David
Ickes again the truth shall set you free
which also has extensive backgrounds and
stuff on the Bilderbergers on all these
different folks my question to you is
what do you think of that missile
defense system which sounds more like a
tracking system aka NSA or NSC yeah
exactly I think the thing that really
makes me wonder about the missile
defense system is that according
information I've haven't according to
people who are involved in it it's
mostly pointing out rather than pointing
in and it makes me wonder what are we
preparing against and it also makes me
heart back to Ronald Reagan's speech
before the United Nations when he
started theorizing about an invasion
from space among the names that you
continue to mention in your book john d
rockefeller who's been dead either
since 1937 also andrew carnegie and
andrew mellon right it's a it's
unfortunate but that that you have to go
back and you have to kind of stir around
in history to be able to put the pieces
together and see what was really going
on the very same things are going on
today but if you try to talk about the
people today I mean these are secret
societies these are secret business
deals these are secret economic treaties
and economic agendas and it takes time
to sort all this out this is I think
maybe one of my biggest complaints is is
that the news media today that likes to
style itself is the watchdog in the
media really seems to be more like lap
dogs of the corporate owners they should
be investigating these things and should
be looking into what's really happening
now rather than waiting for 20 or 30
years for conspiracy researchers and for
authors and such as myself to go digging
through it and say oh wow look what
really went on let me go to one point
and ask you to elaborate early on in
your book you say then a little more
than two months after taking office
President Reagan was struck by an
assassin's bullet which for a quarter of
an inch would have propelled George
Herbert Walker Bush into the Oval Office
seven years before his time oddly enough
the brother brother of the would-be
assassin John W Hinckley had scheduled
dinner with bushes son Neil the very
night Reagan was shot hinckley's Texas
oilmen father and George Bush were
longtime friends your point being what
well the point is is that what are the
odds that the the son of a wealthy all
family would end up attempting to
assassinate the president united states
which would only have benefited went one
of their close friends the bushes I the
facts of the facts I'm not trying I'm
not trying to read anything more into
that and then what the facts state but i
just find it that's extremely
interesting and the connections that we
find there was a preacher for example by
the name of Jerry Owen who was good
friends to Sirhan Sirhan and Owens of
course the accused assassin of Robert
Kennedy and Owens sister was dating our
brimmer the man who shot George Wallace
and pretty well through the election of
1972 into an uproar I mean you know how
many these coincidences are we supposed
to put up with before we start thinking
that there may be some conspiracy behind
all this Jensen Beach Florida is next
good morning Mars you just passed Rush
Limbaugh scoop test but you know what
Your Honor percent right I'm going to
tell you why you can always read their
stuff the Council on Foreign Relations
publishes foreign affairs and foreign
policy and they always Telegraph what
they're going to do they do and I read
it and it's available at the library and
one of the things that they're pushing
now is sustainable development and this
is basically what they call in order to
introduce this global governance they're
doing it from the bottom up and they're
doing it from communities through the
program of sustainable development which
bill clinton signed by executive order
in 1992 it's based on UN treaties and
this is what they're doing you can read
about this stuff in foreign affairs
which apparently you do and there are
other publications so congratulations
you're you're right on it thanks caller
sherman oaks california you're next yes
thank you i have a brief question and
I'd like to respond to the answer I
would like to ask your guests if he is a
familiar with a Ford foundations role in
establishing our relationships with
Mexico you know the president just
visited there and I'd like to know if he
knows their role the fort foundation
only vaguely so you'll have to just kind
of move on to the to the response to
that I do know that it was involved and
that's about the extent of it nificant
it probably has more of an effect on
American America's future than anyone
else the Ford Foundation has nine and a
half billion dollars has nothing to do
with the Ford Motor Company it's been
taken over by a liberal cabal for years
they have been financing organizations
like the mexican american legal defense
and education fund the National Council
of La Raza people who are advocating
open borders and if the truth be known
dr. Robert Bach the man who set
immigration policy under Bill Clinton in
the i ns
for the ford foundation for seven years
thanks for the call we'll move on to a
lot of people want a phone in sylmar
california your next good morning hello
um I'm calling about the CFR I've called
several times in the past five years
let's say you know Brian once told me
about two years ago they were going to
really look into the CFR and the
trilateral commission but they've never
done it okay because this guy I have
ever seen that has come on I mean I've
seen a ton of CFR members on seat on
c-span you're the first guy I've ever
seen come on and say hey these guys are
working behind our back yeah solutely
right eighty-nine percent of all the
high-level cabinet members and since
nineteen twenty nine have been members
of the CFR every presidential and
vice-presidential candidate that we had
running this year were members of the
CFR the corporate members this year far
the reason why they don't you don't see
anything in the papers or anything
published about them expensive
self-published is because the publishing
companies are all owned by members of
the CFR uh that is true oh it there's no
doubt about it it's true what we need to
do is we need to have you on this show
for a week for two weeks and but one
other thing I just wanted to mention was
I don't happen to believe in aliens and
I think the reason why that they want to
bring up the alien book is because to
deflect from the CFR book and the
Bilderberger and trilateral commission
book believe me the people who run
c-span they're controlled by the CFR
okay and it's nothing against the host
or Steve nothing against you I'm not
saying you know anything about it all
I'm saying is is that who controls you
know something about it and just about
everybody you have on that's in your
government is connected somehow to the
CFR thanks for the call Jim Morris well
enrichment which means they all think in
in similar terms and have a cent
or outlook I think my my thing is this
their goal as they themselves state I
mean there's really no secrecy about
what they're after and that is they call
it globalization some people have called
it the New World Order it's one world
government one world army one world
economic system one world currency and
yes some of them are even talking about
one world religion now I know that we
are one world and we are when humanity
and so I think that this movement
towards a one-world entity is not
necessarily a bad thing it may even be
inevitable I think my problem is the
secrecy and the deceit that goes on
we're told oh this is just a little
trade agreement it's too its business
commerce it's too obtuse you don't need
to know about this nothing there and
then the next thing you know it's well
it's connected in with the United
Nations and oh well it's connected in
and this thing keeps growing and we're
losing our national sovereignty and and
if everybody agrees to that if everybody
says well we don't want to be the United
States anymore we just want to be the
you know this this branch of the United
Nations huh I wouldn't even have any
kick with that but we're not being told
that and it's being slipped in on us and
I think that these issues need to be on
the table and we need to be discussing
this stuff because my big question is is
that if they achieve their aim and if we
have a one-world government and if it's
one world currency we're all hooked up
to the computer and on like that what is
our guarantee there's some new Hitler
like tyrant won't gain control over that
centralized mechanism and we don't have
that guarantee because we're not even
supposed to be discussing this thanks
caller let me just to the last caller
point out that i mentioned alien agenda
because it's one of the three books that
our guest Jim Marrs has written for no
other reason and if you watch this
network now three networks are radio
station or are a number of websites you
know that we're probably as open as any
organization and cover all points of
view that's why we were formed or an
educational tool created by the cable
industry and not controlled by anyone
else but we appreciate your comment and
we'll go on to huntington new york good
morning
hello mr. Mars and please let me respond
to your comments as far as conspiracies
are concerned and as far as the openness
of the news is concerned I found that
only on c-span and occasionally on
instant news networks like CNN does the
truth leaked out one of those situations
was the iran-contra drugs deal which of
course in the United States is only
known as they're on contrib but the rest
of the world was always known as wrong
contour drugs could you please comment
on that conspiracy and the involvement
of the Bush family in it absolutely the
iran-contra thing was there was a really
an incredible story that kind of got
glossed over by the mass media in this
country it was basically selling old
obsolete arms at exorbitant prices to
the to the rebels and in Central America
in exchange for drugs I've interviewed
pilots who claimed that they brought
drugs back into this country under the
auspices of the US government and landed
it at homestead or Air Force Base in
Florida now this is pretty pretty wild
and it sounds like some kind of
conspiracy theory but if you'll go back
you'll find that these allegations have
been continuing all the way since the
Vietnam War when they said that the CIA
was bringing drugs back in in body bags
and of course the Bush family has had an
integral part in all of this the Bush
family has had a part in our hold the
hill history of the 20th century going
back to Prescott Bush who was connected
with the people who were founding the
Council on Foreign Relations in these
secret societies I think what we really
have here is a classic case of who will
watch the Watchers okay and yes
iran-contra was much bigger than anybody
was led to believe in fact Bill Moyers
on public television actually styled it
as a coup d'etat in this country so I
think that there is a lot of there are a
lot of things going on that we have not
been
given the straightest rate of Jamar is
our guest from Fort Worth Texas will be
with us for another 35 minutes next call
is New Brighton Connecticut good morning
good morning mr. Mars it's really a
breath of fresh air and listen to you
this morning especially when Alan
Greenspan is being powdered like the
grand old grandpa who's going to save us
all from a depression when at any given
time he could spiral us into a
depression just by constricting the flow
of money I also wanted to know um you
know to say that Chuck heart or really
put the whole thing into perspective by
calling instead of a conspiracy
consensus with the control at the CFR
the Bilderbergers and all in that whole
situation in the way the whole world was
being controlled I don't know if you
know Chuck harder but he really has a
lot of quick thoughts like that well let
me point out here that it only seems
like a consensus because all of these
people seem to speak with one voice and
so to the uninitiated it's like oh well
these smart educated thoughtful people
and they all agree so this must be the
way to go again though you have to look
that they're all members of that whole
little Club and you don't get in the
club unless you agree with them to begin
with you also pointed out that President
Jimmy Carter's administration was so
filled with members of the trilateral
commission that conspiracy researchers
had a field day early on his
administration he was the gentleman who
ran as the outsider that's exactly right
except the reason that it became very
obvious during the Carter Administration
that the trilateral commission had so
much to do with that was that no one had
heard of Jimmy Carter until nineteen
seventy-two when he was picked up and
inducted into the trilateral commission
and then within just a few years he
suddenly becomes president United States
his cabinet and his administration were
just rife with with a trilateral list
and to the point to where even the
Washington Post and other mass media
were forced to take notice of all this
I'd also point out that in the election
of 1980 when Ronald Reagan was running
and he was running again as an outsider
trying to get into Washington in some of
the contentious primaries they had
New Hampshire Ronald Reagan pledged that
if he was elected president he would
investigate the Council on Foreign
Relations and he also pointed out that
George Herbert Walker Bush was a big
ranking member of these organizations
and that he would never allow George
Bush to have a place in his
administration and then when the
convention came along it was clear that
Reagan was going to get the nomination
the only question was who was going to
be vice president and the media pundits
of the mass media suddenly began talking
about a dream ticket with Ronald Reagan
as president and former President Gerald
Ford his vice president but of course
Gerald Ford having been president if
that was to take place should have be
able to pick half the cabinet well so
suddenly faced with this growing
pressure coming from CFR members that
honed these big media Reagan quite
unconventionally rushed into the
Republican convention late one night 11
or 1130 as I recall and said oh there's
something going on here and I'm sorry
this is kind of unusual but we need to
put a stop to this and I choose George
Bush is my running mate and after that
you never heard a word about the Council
on Foreign Relations Wantagh New York is
next for author Tim Mars good morning
Thank You mr. Mars I was wondering if
you could discuss something about how
you know three or four administration's
Nixon Carter Reagan Bush sold arms to
Iran and Iraq so they could have a
10-year war against each other and then
when the war came winding down against
them III think Iraq wanted to raise
prices on oil and Kuwait wouldn't and
then they had meetings with OPEC and
Iraq was demanding that they raised the
prices and Kuwait said no and then they
massed troops along the Kuwaiti border
there and you can see that on satellite
photos there for months and months and
you could you could see that it was
almost like Bush gave him a wink and a
nod like you know do if something's
going to happen you know we'll look the
other way and then they did invade and
then they was almost like they had dark
eyes my like oh we can't believe you did
that you know why would you do something
like that and we sold out we saw the
those arms to iran and iraq and i was
wonder if you get to discuss the general
Schwarzkopf father being the you know
the head the guy who trained the i the
the Iranian secret police and I was
wondering if he could discuss something
about well I don't know about aliens but
Rudy Giuliani looks like one and George
Bush talks like one knows what if we
could just move you fill me in on
something like that on occasions there
Thank You caller well I'm not going to
try to identify who's nailin who's not I
mean who knows you know that's a you
know we get too paranoid I mean if
you're sitting in theater and the guy
next to you know you don't know if he's
alien or a Republican or what you know
but yeah the Gulf War and that whole
situation obviously was just a deal
first you have to understand Kuwait was
quite illegally carved out of Iraq early
on and with usually mostly through the
strength of British troops that were
sent over there in the early 60s so Iraq
has always considered Kuwait to be part
of that country that had been taken from
it and so when Saddam Hussein and as you
so correctly pointed out begin to try to
figure out a way to make more money so
he could pay out all these crushing
debts that he had incurred by fighting
that eight-year war with a run at the
hest of the United States okay and his
buddy George Herbert Walker Bush he
decided that he would move into Kuwait
and try to take over those oil reserves
to to boost his income so when he calls
in the American ambassador April blessed
be he asked her he says you know what
are your thoughts on this if we go back
to our original borders and she said
well I've been instructing to tell you
that we that's an Arab situation and we
don't have any particular thought on
that so I mean that sounds kind of like
do what you want to do to me and yet
soon as he made his move then he's
styled as the new Hitler and we
mobilized to go over there and we start
setting up permanent basis that we are
still Manning in the Middle East and a
lot of things happen I think the thing
that was most puzzling about that to me
until you understand who's really
running the show and what their agenda
is is the fact that they they actually
unleash the yes military there and let
them do
thing and they did a fantastic job they
defeated the third or fourth largest
army in the world you know in just a
matter of weeks but as we were closing
in and as we could have ended that whole
situation you know it all just stopped
and Saddam Hussein of course is still
there we're still bombing him and
blowing money on ordinance and
everything else and the poor Iraqi
people good not god knows what they've
gone through and what it was that all
about I can't help but think that Saddam
Hussein picked up the telephone call
those international bankers and said
okay I'll I'll start paying my interest
again if you'll stop and everything
stopped the book is called ruled by
secrecy by harpercollins Jim Marrs is
our guest he is in Fort Worth Texas a
reporter who has been did you grow up in
Texas yes Fort Worth as matter of fact
is my hometown let's get another call
Baltimore good morning call you with us
enjoying the program very much mr. Mars
I have your book alien agenda I loved it
and I know you're not a kook but I
wanted to talk about the Federal Reserve
when I tell my friends that the central
bank is neither federal nor reserve they
think I'm an idiot be that as it may the
question I have is very simply put is
the basic ripoff or premise that the
bank buys the money for the face for the
for the cost of the printing then sells
it back to us at face value plus
interest have I been misinformed or is
that the basic premise of the rip-off
well that's pretty much it of course
that's a very broad generalization but
it's about it Congress authorizes debt
and once they've authorized the debt
then the Federal Reserve System spends a
few hundred dollars on ink and paper and
prints up millions and millions of
dollars worth of money which they then
distribute to their 12 member banks now
under fractional banking they can loan
out you know ten times more than what
they actually have on deposit which
means that then they can that's how you
can control the expansion or contraction
of currency within the country and
that's how you can control the economy
that we've seen an example of this here
recently with the 87 stock market crash
and Alan Greenspan perhaps illegally
began to loosen up on all the rules and
regulations to keep the economy propped
up and one of the things that they
loosened up on was that it used to be
you could not offer public stock in a
company that was not on a profitable
basis and yet somewhere they changed the
rules and over the last few years we've
seen the rise of these high-tech dot-com
companies that went out borrowed
millions of dollars you know just
because they were dot-com companies and
then they started issuing public stock
and people rushing with money in hand
trying to invest in these new dot-com
companies and the whole thing ballooned
up until about the middle of last year
and then it blew up and now the dot-com
companies are hurting the investors have
lost all their money and their out
borrowing more money the barring for
high-tech companies increased from 1998
until this year from ninety eight
billion dollars to over a trillion
dollars now who profits from all of that
people who loaned the money the people
who deal in the money and the brokerage
firms that skim all the money off the
top and then let it go and it's the poor
old investors and the poor people who
put all their hopes and dreams into
these dot-com companies that are now
left standing around Newport North
Carolina good morning good morning how
are you mr. Mars thank you for your
refreshing view of gemstone files was
something you're smiling was something
that in Southern California during the
70's and 80's was a very popular report
on the geopolitical economic secret
goings-on in American politics can you
give us a little bit more information on
that please well the gemstone fouled was
has floated around for years I have a
copy of the old original one and then I
have lots of magazine articles and some
some people who have all looked into it
and basically it's it's a
behind-the-scenes alternative view of
what was going on it involves the
Kennedy assassination it
elves aristotle onassis it involves a
lot of things I think the only comment I
could make on it is is that much of it
seems to be true and to be documented
some of it cannot be you know proven one
way or another my big come it is is that
I think something like this that makes
the allegations that the gemstone files
has should be investigated okay where's
the news media they should be looking
into that if it's not true we need to
know that if it is true we definitely
need to know that knoxville tennessee
good morning yes Jim appreciates you I
agree one hundred percent with you I
wish more people would talk about this
regarding the spear far and things if
everybody that was in the public eye
belong to the National Dental
Association people would say that's
peculiar but you know everybody belongs
to see if our nobody bats an eye but the
color before you mentioned the desert
storm I think the desert storm plot was
basically made our United Nation army
household name and Americans viewpoint
yeah i think i agree i think that was
part of the purpose behind the gulf war
was to further cement the idea that the
united nations army you know can go
anywhere do anything it's really rushing
pell-mell upon us just before leaving
office bill clinton reversed himself and
said that he would sign up the united
states for a world Criminal Court now
this is again is a good example of what
goes on here because on the one hand and
at one level that would seem like
they'll that's a really good idea now
maybe we can go after some of those war
criminals in in Albania or Kosovo or
wherever okay and yet people don't think
through the whole thing if that
mechanism is set into place then what is
to prevent the world Criminal Court from
sending the UN World army to your house
and arresting you for some environmental
violation or perhaps because you own a
gun and they've decided that that we
should all be disarmed
or whatever and you're brought up to
trial before a panel of people who are
not even Americans and therefore have no
understanding much less a loyalty to the
Constitution of the Bill of Rights I
think that we need to start paying
attention to what's happening here the
BBC parliamentary channel carry see
spend programming including this show
live on Sunday afternoons Livingston
Scotland is next I will miss tomorrow
hello it was what sorry I was wondering
if you had any if he had had done any
better walk on GC and the jack will
start quote how are you still with us
I'm sorry you might want to elaborate a
little bit more with your question well
they seem to come in a Breton by a lot
of defense companies up defense
companies were prior you're quite
successful and the chosen fields and
they just suddenly come in after the
Gulf War and bought enough homegrown but
I disguise defense companies which was
supplying stuff to the British and
European nations well yeah if I catch
your drift yes we have to understand
that you know the United States for all
the rhetoric we have about peace and
security to say the other thing we are
the largest arms dealer in the world the
arms is still the leading export of the
United States and so again we have to
consider that when we when they're
talking about missile defense and and
national security and and this that the
other thing we are also talking about
our primary business concern since the
call was from Scotland let me go to page
257 of your book the bombing of Pan Am
flight 103 that crashed just over
Lockerbie several investigators have
claimed that a major force behind the p2
Lodge was the highly secret Freemason
grin alpine lodge of Switzerland whose
membership includes almost everyone of
any importance in that nation of banks
former british prime minister and
Bilderberger Harold Wilson called Alpine
Lodge members the gnomes of Zurich
claiming they had more power than any
government p 2 was implicated in several
acts of terrorism beginning with the
1980 bombings of the Bologna train
station which killed 85 people and
possibly even plant Panem
like 103 you point out that the victims
included a CIA team on its way to
Washington to do what okay the story is
in this story by the way is not some
conspiracy theory this story was
developed by the insurance investigators
for Pan Am that said that they're in the
basically the story goes as this there
was a team of CIA specialists that went
to the Middle East and discovered that
other CIA members there were part of a
drug-smuggling ring they tried to alert
Washington higher Washington authorities
who basically turned a cold shoulder so
they were on their way back with the
evidence and the documentation to see if
they couldn't get this cleaned up when
the bomb went off of course over
lockerbie scotland we are they are now
in the process of having the trial for
these Libyan terrorist and of course you
don't hear much about that the media
because the trials not going very well
the truth seems to be trying to force
its way out and again the media's pretty
much caught short hand in that reporting
next call Destin Florida good morning
good morning mr. Marsh I have a simple
question for you in your opinion who is
the most powerful person in the world
and what gives him or her that power
thank that's an excellent question i
really don't think there's a whole lot
of question about it i think anybody
who's hey heavens their head up and
their eyes open looking around would
probably agree with me that the most
powerful person in the world today is
Alan Greenspan okay that heads our
Federal Reserve System and I don't know
about those of you out there in the
listening audience but I don't recall
ever voting for alan greenspan for
anything but there he is and he pretty
well dick takes what's going to happen
he can raise an eyebrow and markets roll
all over the world and of course Alan
Greenspan is a big member of the Council
on Foreign Relations of these secret
societies his predecessor Paul Volcker
has moved on now to become I think he's
the chairman of the
north north american chairman for the
trilateral commission I mean it's all
part of that same good old boy network
that has been running the government
were been running our economic system
for at least the 20th century if not
before do you draw any connection
between Alan Greenspan and his wife
Andrea Mitchell of NBC News well other
than the fact that they you know his
wife also has a position of authority
and I'm sure that she probably thinks
along similar lines and has a similar
world out out looked Alan Greenspan
again I don't think an alan greenspan he
may not be a bad guy he mean he may not
be trying to plot to take over the world
he may be simply a very able
administrator again we have to look at
the way things or worked in the military
and intelligence in the business world
we usually find what i call the pyramid
of power which is at the very top are
the people who make the decisions and
who truly set the real agenda and then
trickling on down you get the people
down below you get middle managers and
they are in most instances to one degree
or another abele carrying on
administrating these plans so Alan
Greenspan may be simply an able
administrator but we have to identify I
think the people who are really making
these decisions and the people who are
pushing us into globalization and are
losing our national sovereignty in the
process and we have to look and see what
you know is this truly what we want Jim
Marrs now lives in paradise Texas which
is just north of Fort Worth is a former
reporter with the fort worth
star-telegram and the author of a number
of books including alien agenda
crossfire and is latest by harpercollins
ruled by secrecy next is Miami Florida
good morning good morning mr. Mars it's
very refreshing to hear you I wanted to
ask you something these people are
working very quickly with respect to the
imposition of the New World Order and
their concentration camps all throughout
the United States and also filled things
also in military
relations and another point I wanted to
bring up is the power that astre was
hiding Cuba for 42 years and the beast
destabilization of all of Latin America
and the other thing the last thing is
how long do you think before there could
be a possible civil war in this country
if these people keep pushing the this
agenda thank you well I would certainly
hope that there would never be another
civil war in this country and and I
frankly I think the chances are somewhat
slim because there's one big secret that
we have that they don't and that is
there's more of us than there are them
and if everybody understood what the
true situation was and and said no I'm
not sure we want to go along with that
then the game's over you know that's it
the only reason that they're pushing us
as fast as they are into the new world
order is because they have control over
the mass media microphone and therefore
most people are not aware that this is
going on and and that's basically my
only purpose I'm not even here to make
judgments and say it's good it's bad we
should fight against it we should resist
I'm not sure but I think that it needs
to be on the table and we need to be
discussing this and we need to be
looking at it with our eyes wide open
for example the last civil war we had
which and I will certainly admit to
being a buff on the War Between the
States okay and there's a ton of books
out there and people are continuing
leery evaluating lincoln and robert e
lee and i like that and of course
there's millions of people whose very
closely study those battles and those
leaders and they may they may know more
about the Battle of Antietam than they
do about who's running the country today
and yet in researching from my book
ruled by secrecy what I found was that
the experience of america between
eighteen sixty and 1865 was a plot and
that's not just me saying that the
German Chancellor Otto von Bismarck said
this was a plot by the European bankers
to split the United States
between north and south let them bleed
each other dry and then they were going
to move in and try to regain North
America for the European powers okay and
if you go back and think about it from
your history class you realize that the
British had their military and lots of
troops poised in Canada and it was a big
haven for the Confederates and the in
Mexico we had the French army under
Maximilian so yeah they were poised and
ready to take over Indianapolis your
next good morning yes good morning I I
wanted to give a book the truth shall
set you free have you read it mr. Mars
yes I have I saw in this book it were
the United States even funded some
Hussein to fight us and bush and the sad
thing divided many many billions of
dollars over oil money well that seems
to be established representative Henry
Gonzales established that a lot of the
money that was backed by US taxpayer
guarantees was going to Saddam Hussein
and he was using that instead of buying
food and stuff he was buying military
equipment which he then turned around
and used against our own troops this is
nothing new during the height of the
Vietnam War at the behest of his wise
men advisors all of whom were Council on
Foreign Relations members Lyndon Johnson
advanced more loans and more money to
Russia than even at the height of World
War two when they were allies so we had
the spectacle during Vietnam of US
taxpayer money going to Russia as loans
which they use to build facilities such
as the Kama River truck factory cranked
out war supplies which they shipped to
North Vietnam and was used to kill our
boys now that doesn't seem to make any
sense at all until you understand that
these people who are at the apex of the
power pyramid in these secret societies
are profiting from all of this they're
profiting from this because you have to
understand that the people who are in
the business
money they are fun at sears their
bankers there whatever okay they deal in
trade and sell and buy money debt equals
profit the more debt there is the more
interest there is the more money they
make and once you understand that one
little simple thing then you understand
why that we spend all this money bombing
Kosovo five hundred million dollars to
rebuild the infrastructure and Kosovo
somebody's got to borrow that money okay
that's what just always remember debt
equals profit and then you begin to
understand the headlines Warroad
Minnesota is next for Jim Mora's good
morning mr. Mars I've read some of your
books before what a particular dark
Majesty and that was several years ago
now and I was interested to see that
you're on the phone this morning are on
the TV this morning that's great to see
you well just last minute I think you
have me mixed up with text Mars oh
excuse me yeah yeah that's a he's a
different fellow and even though we do
have the same last name and I have
talked with Tex Mars but as far as I
know there's no relation will move on to
Columbia Maryland good morning to you uh
hello yes I was a good morning mr. Mars
good morning hi you may be the person
I've been puzzled about something for
quite over over a period of time and you
may be the person who possibly could
enlighten me well answers are free yeah
you're right truthful answers are five
dollars what's your question caller sure
a George Shultz was the secretary of
state I believe under Ronald Reagan if
I'm I could be fuzzy on that but I I
mention it because as something very
strange happened at the time I was
watching a press conference mr. Schultz
was being asked questions and someone
asked him a question what he thought
should be done about drugs I'm and he
said well it's a obviously that you
should legalize the drug trade because
it's a big black market and that's
the whole problem with it and all of a
sudden it was like something had shut
down or something couldn't ask any more
questions or by about that or sun a big
effort was made to redirect the subject
that's right that's right because see we
can't maintain the drug profits and all
that drug money that flows through the
banking systems you know if drugs were
legalized you know I mean it's just
prohibition to in prohibition one we
they try to outlaw alcohol and not only
outlawed it they passed a constitutional
amendment against it and sure enough if
there is any a drug that could be proven
to cause social disruption and problems
it's alcohol and and yet we didn't learn
from that experience that by trying to
outlaw it all we did was create a giant
criminal underground and the money that
flows through illegal alcohol and today
illegal drugs is a totally corrupting
influence on police and law enforcement
and and the legal system and everything
else and it only took our grand great
grandfathers and great grandmothers a
little over ten years maybe about 1213
years to figure out that alcohol
prohibition not only was not working but
it was creating a bigger problem than
the alcohol itself and here after 30
years or more of drug prohibition we
still can't seem to address the issue in
terms of anything other than more
prisons and tougher laws and on like
that I think it's time that we as a
people start thinking about what's going
on instead of just reacting to the
hysteria that's whipped up by the very
people who are profiting from the flow
of the drug money through the banking
system and then go back in history
ancient history who created the pyramids
well who created the pyramids well we're
all told that it was those primitive old
ancient Egyptians but the problem is
that's not true there is now evidence of
vertical water erosion on the Sphinx and
to some degree on the Great Pyramid
which indicates that it set out under
heavy rains under a long period of time
and we also know that those heavy rains
like that have not occurred on the Giza
Plateau
for for at least ten thousand five
hundred years well that's five or six
thousand years before the Egyptians ever
came along and this again is a big
secret that's going on is that the
history of the world in the history of
humanity is now taking some very
definite turns it's not what we've been
taught Atlanta good morning for Jim
Marrs good morning I appreciate it sir
mr. Mars I believe that it's a
conspiracy industry really wanted to
figure this problem out and we're just
inoculating us they share the truth
which is so obvious Jefferson spelled it
out in eighteen letter 1810 letter to
Samuel kercheval about the people who
stole the heritage of the Jewish
nationalists that was put to death under
Roman law against the second offense /
sedition and came right down to the
president and killed John Kennedy in
your neighboring town because he ordered
us out of there a lot of fun diem
fiefdom of Vietnam Vietnam was a Roman
Catholic slave plantation the CFR is
done by the Rockefellers who is the
papal bank Prescott Bush is a member of
the knights of malta who financed Adolf
Hitler as a Rockefeller retainer this is
all a Roman plot the civil war that
divided the European bankers were the
papal bankers that during the time when
the Pope was speaking against the
liberalism and how the this synagogue of
Satan was running America that the anti
jus anti-communist anti-liberal these
are all divide and conquer terms in
order to further the Catholic the
universal Church run by the black
aristocracy who is the same he trusts in
clans who built Rome to begin with and
you can read about it in the secrets of
the Gotha you can read about why the
press doesn't back this up because
there's been taken over by the mob and
you read about that in unholy toledo by
omen during the circulation wars the
early part of the 1900s thanks for the
call jim marrs right well yeah yeah he
touched on so many things there are some
of which I cover in my book rule by
secrecy but what you have here is you
have so many levels you can view things
on different levels this past election
you can view that is just just an
election between the limit and Democrats
and Republicans or you can view that as
a election between conservatives and
liberals or you can view that as a
exercise in how to steal an election
well by both parties they both were
trying okay or you can look on that as
an exercise in in destroying one of the
last unifying institutions of the
American public which is the the belief
in the sanctity of our vote you know
which we now see is it may not be there
so you look at all these at various
levels and it's like the caller was
saying a lot of facts he was bouta ng is
are undoubtedly true it depends on how
you look at it I think my point is is
that unfortunately the media the
corporate control mass media only wants
us to see one view of our national life
and of our history and everything else
and that view is demonstrably wrong in
many instances and I just feel like that
we'd all be a lot better off if we would
start dealing with the truth and how
we're going to get to the truth not by
ignoring the conspiracy theories not by
ignoring alternative history and
alternative sources of information but
by putting it all out there so we can
all look at it and so we can all make up
our own minds we have about a minute
left last call very quickly Verona
Virginia good morning yes hi I was
wondering the other night when I saw you
on the History Channel and you mentioned
a microchip society do you compare that
to anything in the Bible well of course
there's this whole idea about in
Revelations where they talk about no one
will be able to do business without the
mark of the beast and a lot of people
are beginning to suspect that that may
have to do with microchip and computer
but then people have interpreted that
through centuries so I guess we'll just
have to kind of wait and see Jim Marrs
the book is called rule by secrecy
thanks very much for joining us and we
will definitely have to have you come
back on again sometime soon thank you
Steve appreciate your time